everybody wants to wake up and feel like
what they're going to do matters
fulfillment comes from feeling like
you're creating something that's going
to matter to somebody else not just for
yourself not just a selfish Pursuit but
we all want to feel like today is going
to matter I'm going to make something
that's going to matter for somebody else
and some of us you and I we want to have
a big impact change the world do big
things and other people they just want
to help the people around them their
family if you woke up every day and felt
like today doesn't matter nobody cares
if I show up or not it doesn't make any
difference that's the path down to
anxiety and stress and depression and
suicide in a lot of dark places but if
you felt like today was going to matter
and you're going to make something today
that may not change the world but can
touch one person's life like it means
something to one person that's the path
to a fulfilling life